[Applaudissements]
l'image est devenue virale et a
rapidement fait le tour du monde
filmé par un passant elle montre un
jeune homme en train d'escalader la
façade d'un immeuble à paris pour
secourir un enfant suspendu dans le vide
un geste incroyable de bravoure
c'est lui partout en france mamoutou
gassama un malien sans papiers de 22 ans
est aujourd'hui considéré comme un héros
sens quand je vois la hauteur du coup je
suis hyper contente pour ce jeune homme
je pense qu'il a fait naturellement et
qui pensait pas que ça allait avoir ses
répercussions
le jeune malienne volontiers il n'a pas
beaucoup réfléchi avant de risquer sa
vie et je suis pourri pour régaler les
solutions pour qu'ils aient pu le sauver
et jimmy choo bolton 5e menteuse
rapidement un mouvement de solidarité
soutient se mettent en place pour aider
mamoudou gassama à obtenir ses papiers
moins de 36 heures après le sauvetage
il est reçu par le président de la
république au palais de l'elysée
[Musique]
effectivement à penser démons
cette année
un pc du mois se montrent actuellement
12h30 pour un acte de courage récompensé
d'une médaille
ça me fait plaisir ça psa paierait parce
que c'est ma première fois de gagner
comme cela mais surtout emmanuel macron
lui a offert la nationalité française et
un travail chez les pompiers de paris
parce que c'est ce même esprit que nos
sapeurs pompiers portent chaque jour et
plus sérieusement je crois que le
caractère exceptionnel de ce geste
justifier les décisions exceptionnelles
que nous avons prises
c'est la deuxième fois en quelques
années que malien sans-papier s'illustre
en france par sa bravoure la seule
batterie s'est lui aussi dû offrir la
nationalité française
après avoir sauvé plusieurs personnes en
janvier 2015
lors de la prise d'otages à l'épicerie
cacher de paris mamoudou gassama lui qui
habite en centre d'accueil à montreuil
en banlieue paris vient d'être faire
citoyen d'honneur de la ville
et si jean françois bélanger
radio-canada paris